a three-minute tournament
let's see what we get
57 minute tournament
III on move one is definitely different
hmm all right I'm not going to do
anything special
I can't get in a five so hmm Bishop to
d3
okay it's a very odd beginning
very odd beginning alright I want my
knight on c6 but my C pawn wants to play
a very very odd start can't go to the
castle there I would have maybe play d5
let's put my bishop here I guess
it's first time playing this opponent
ceefor do I take just keep the tension
I
I'll have anything on the H file so
let's just get on with castles on pond
takes I don't think I want to take with
the pawn I don't want to be saddled with
an isolated pawn
really controlling d4 I'm expecting this
to strike really really soon and
actually another thing is that I'm maybe
yeah I think maybe I should have gone
with a bit more modest deployment with
my Bishop to e7 all right I'm going to
go here
they're not gonna let me get into that
square let's start with this and I think
I just want to take again
Queen takes all exchange I did this
voluntary exchange because I didn't want
I didn't want my knight to be pushed
away it's hard to say who's better I
think it's just even what's up but let's
avoid the Queen exchange and I'm kind of
hoping in a way that their queen will
struggle to find a good square and then
that moves played I guess here is it
white looking for some trouble like
Queen trap trouble all right let's all
right let's go here rook takes Knight I
have rook takes Queen if I did yes there
is rook takes Knight
why not just up the exchange now they
thought
how to take like this I just go right
here I'm off the exchange could have
considered Bishop f6 as well let's do it
now
Nighy rook here is not a good idea let's
go back my bishop is a very confused
piece very confused a very confused
piece maybe I just scooped my King on
over here
alright we're gonna we're gonna keep
this Knight out of e5 he's he's had
enough fun
let's go here
you know these guys could easily drop
off their night is really strong really
down on time now let's do it like this
let's expand a little bit
let's go over here I just want to stay
clear that night such a dangerous piece
let's try for this
not the greatest way ever to try not
activate my king I do not mind seeing
that do you not have a lot of time
that's helpful because I could win this
pawn now
maybe go after
really boxing out my king
they're being very annoying King here
and then push actually I want to play
King here next
hmm where is my time
jeez this night is so tricky so tricky I
want to get behind the pawns eat my king
very far away from my rook
I think I could do that
how they could block with the night
forgot that they can block with the
night
they're offering a drum and still going
to try to win
oh I am winning now
you
whoo that was a very odd ball game there
are so many moments in that game that
struck me as very bizarre I don't know
weird the opening in particular
No
that uh obstructing the c-pawn and that
little that earlier night maneuver
no no no all right we got the W but it
felt weird something about that felt
weird
okay how about a Kings Indian I play
this opening much more than I do
Grune Feld actually let's just switch
gears I don't want to allow them to
acquire a pawn duo so easily so let's
bring the bishop out so we got another
case where this C pawn is obstructed
alright so I guess they just don't want
to see the knight pinned when they play
here now they're going after my throat
fine alright looking for this and then
this stuff if this is the idea I could
claim you know White has lost some time
they played h3 and then only later
they're gonna try for h4 let's jump on
in the center
maybe I should have prefaced that with
first knight c6 so the knight Knight
here isn't a reply if I do decide to
take with the pawn and strike at the
knight but now actually if the knight
place here I have f6 so yes to find a
new home if he goes here I'm definitely
going to duck don't want this knight
that's on the edge taking out my bishop
getting trapped so do I just go all the
way home all the way home
the threat here I believe is f6 and then
g5 in the night is out of squares
currently no good move for this guy if I
went here I think they would have just
pushed here and if I go here well I'm in
my queen
my Queens way and knights way
so let's see what is white gonna come up
with here all right they're just going
for a dark square bishop exchange I
could also just push in the center throw
a strike at the night with my queen I
actually like that let's go two squares
okay so now I'm hitting this twice as
defended twice but now they have to do
g3 I don't see any other move than g3 I
could just trade Queens I'm gonna go
with that approach
and simply follow up with f5 I will gain
a tempo at this guy with this guy with
Knight to c6 let's form a nice pawn
chain he's still out of bounds out of
play
they're trying to break down my
structure let's bring the knight out
first if the rook releases pressure here
maybe I consider f4 yeah I kind of like
that let's go at that form
if the night goes here g5 and he's
having a tough day actually now this
night is a dead piece if I can maintain
this structure so I'm thinking about
just pushing
there's something better
no not necessarily dead piece actually
if I go here then there's this and then
a night reroute to c5 can also take and
then just put my rook on the seventh
I'm gonna go with that push push here
takes takes rook takes the rook is gonna
get some activity let's try this
chewed up a lot of time just then
yeah all right this is definitely a
little bit awkward maybe this was more
accurate
after the king are going after the night
I'm gonna do it now going after the
night with my king and he's trapped if I
did this he just jumps forward
they could damage my queenside structure
but this night is very loose piece and
he is going down isn't he
I don't think my king is fearing any
mating that's being on the edge it's
close all right
taking out some some stuff here maybe
push my king around but I'm there still
trying to make me
let's go here so I wanna I want to get
this in they can't stop me from getting
h6 but if I did this first they could
have stopped me from getting to f7 with
Brooke here
now let's do this able to consolidate
rook takes I have a skewer
let's just double stay coordinated I'm
fine with an exchange and I just want to
soften up this structure I have a square
if they give a check didn't I do this in
the last game my king
working along the edge like this scoop
up this pawn get out of the pawns way
and promote keep on pushing
they're also down on time back to
tournament
yeah after that Queen exchange I'm not
sure if that Queen exchange was the
right approach I'm thinking they should
have played g5 to stop that very idea of
King h6 King g5 I don't know
tough to say
forty-three minutes left in this one the
top guy
Timothy Coe
all right I don't think we've played uh
okay let's start with the Knight f3 game
Knight f3 d4 alright
rune Feld or not will I be playing the
white end of a grünfeld or Kings Indian
Kings Indian it is alright Bishop b2
okay let's go with
let's go with castles
v5 is expected granting the night that
c5 Square and let's go with now let's go
with this idea of night 2 e1 I'm doing
this so that the night can't get out of
the pawns way and move forward
I'm going to take this bishop actually
now you take me maybe now I'll take the
bishop
and before f5 can be played I'm in a
playoff 3 I'm anticipating this advance
and let's strike at the night if they
have to take away from okay I'm gonna
I'm gonna do this and I believe I'm
going to take here
no I'll do this if they do this they
have their their most let's go here
thinking about this advance at some
point I could push this through okay
they're looking to control that
I was gonna say if they shut it down
their most important attacking piece in
this the black side of a Kings Indian is
no longer around so I'm kind of fine
with the two minor piece type position
in the position being locked down with
f4
you
let's um all right that night is gonna
be really strong on d6 I'm prepared to
just take them out let's see how they
recapture and I'm gonna keep it really
closed
yeah let's go here we're shutting down
the queenside with that move and I'm
focused on the kingside now
Bishop's trying to get active I don't
want allow him to get to d4
they're insisting though okay I'm okay
if the if they the Queens are exchanged
that's happening
good night versus bad bishop though at
the moment my night doesn't have a great
square where would I want them be five
I'm also down at time quite a bit and
then I'll centralize I need to open
stuff up a little bit
let's get that pawn out of harm's way
how do I open this up properly try 4g4
I'd really like to get this square some
night maneuver
it's tough
let's try this see how they react they
go here I think I want to do this to
ensure that it opens up some that's a
good move
my knight can't go too far because they
could take and then enter here I don't
think I have anything they could just
sit h6 I think is a good move yes
because I was intending on maybe playing
G a capture and then g5 I don't think I
could do anything my time is also not so
great
bishop here i threaten you to take twice
and then put my knight on e4 but i'm
just so down on time so down on time
you know I don't think there's anything
yeah it's already a draw by repetition I
was ready to say I'm gonna offer a drop
yeah they they did well they're at the
end with the maintaining the tension
they didn't really give me an inch you
know that maybe I was too quick let's
try it let's try a leaf organ maybe I
was too quick with
let's try and open Sicilian maybe I was
too quick with taking their Bishop on c5
a dragon alright let's let's try some
classical stuff
don't know a great setup really on the
white end just f4 let's go Queen d2 rook
to e1 my F pawn needs to play at some
point I believe once get implying where
did all my time go on that game as well
let's avoid the night exchange
even though I wouldn't it wouldn't be an
attack I still think it's a good idea to
get rid of this guy there's no great
definition to the structure so I don't
know that we could what's with this
Bishop g4 stuff second game in a row
Bishop g4 I'm not saying it's a bad move
just odd to see the same one come about
again this may be this where I was
losing time in that last game the Bishop
g4 move rattled me
alright let's still go for this I was
gonna say there's no definition yet with
the structure we can't identify good
good or bad bishops it's a completely
open dag and all a very important
defender for the King even though it is
same sides castling so let's get him out
of there and I don't want to be kicked
with this guy
so they could take and force me to take
away from the center and they're
preparing this advance
all right let's go here
not 100% sure why off of this file
protect the dog and I'll think it's a
fine square could still go in for be
four and then the night would be
striking at c2 so that that will really
wasn't scaring I thought I thought they
could just go with d5
that move is striking here
a little bit annoying
I don't know let's just put the knight
in the center
okay so offering a queen exchange huh
can't really do too much to avoid that
just gonna take that's a good move all
right let's give him a shove Bishop
versus Knight position
you know the rook recaptures and is
protecting their yeah let's let's take
the night out
surprised that their thinking here oh
they're thinking about night here I
could save my ninth out two minor pieces
versus the rook is that what Sam is
thinking about
thinking about this that wouldn't be
good
hmm I'm not sure what black is thinking
about here okay I think I just have to I
think that night is just intolerable so
time for the Kings to play I don't want
to see this move happen too easily let's
stop it look to pile up
King on d4 pile-up on c4 is the is the
plan and get there fast too
guess we're gonna take get to the center
they've come over here I think I have to
contest it
here
so they have to be careful let's go with
this pawn I don't I don't want to give
this square up if I did this then they
have mating ideas actually they could
still do this kind of stuff I think I
have to be really careful I'm close to
getting mated wait a second
the
three take-take-take taking here that's
a one King and pawn endgame takes takes
everything takes king here I take here
and I have two ponds
two outside passers you know this is a
one King and pawn end game I do this and
then get right back here on d4 I should
have seen that move or two sooner
because I think they had a quick
transfer to the e-file with an idea of
sacking one rook and then mating me it's
just centralized this was maybe more
accurate one pawn restricting to now I
have this opportunity to do this move I
could have also captured and pushed but
now I do this
and now we go here 11 seconds should be
plenty
19 seconds and they're going after my
pawns
whoa
you
I didn't like my technique there it's
going to be enough
mmm that wasn't the greatest conversion
there at the end okay
oh where do we stand still fishing for a
for I have ate all twos
31 minutes and change remaining
let's see who we got next first-place
guy a little speed bump there okay let's
try and let's try another
okay let's kick off with D for D for C
for
Neil Slava Roni
okay III
Bishop there what do I do um let's just
develop and now look to create an
imbalance night for Bishop exchange okay
that's a little bit awkward normally
it's one of these three you don't allow
that to happen so I have the bishop pair
let's uh let's immediately throw some
fire on these light squares where where
black is very sensitive now
I do this Queen takes pawn takes Bishop
moves b4 b5 cannot be prevented so I
will be able to undo all this is just a
temporary doubling of the be pawns I
have the time to get this in black still
needs three moves actually to stop b5 so
I don't have to do that straightaway I
could still do something else what's
that something else
what would I like to do here
g3
just prevent any pawn advance here now
we do this because now that the rook is
protected they were threatening a6 and I
wouldn't be able to get this in so we're
seeing b5 right now and we might see b5
later the return of a beep on
let's develop prepare to get my king off
of this file
oh they had an opportunity for f4 I
think let's just Castle Knight takes I'd
have doubled see pawns but the see pawn
can on
I think I need to get rid of this night
maybe Bishop d3 at the end wasn't such a
good idea but I still have this plan of
expanding on the queenside where I have
some space let's take and then b5 and so
at the end of all these pawn advances on
the Queen side what has happened I
acquire a passed pawn connected passed
pawn I'm up upon right now not the
healthiest of pawns and also maybe this
is a target I don't know liability or an
asset let's see Black's next move is if
they allow this they're in big trouble
stop that
I don't have much time
okay let's put the rook here or rook the
bishop here I think I just want one rook
exchange
I think they after prepared to double
rooks is if I get anything here okay
we're going with this rook because I
want to be able to sneak over with my
king somewhere close to the center I go
here right now I think I could do that
I'm gonna help
double
King is opposite my bishop
let's put pressure on them
so my bishop will be the one to blockade
let's just keep the knight out of g4
rook takes rook I end up recapturing
with the pawn and there's a fork
you know what maybe this is the approach
break down the structure some
this night is a bit of a clumsy piece
let's do this let's see what diagonal
opens up now this night is cooked
it's a pin that you just can't get out
of rook takes rook is no good yeah they
threw in the towel
okay what's the what's the big takeaway
from that one I believe Queen b6
may come off as a bit too strong but
Queen b6 might just be a losing move
I don't think it would read that like on
the evaluation straightaway but
I don't know there's a lot of things
tipping in White's favor
bishop air space and an active avenue
for the rooks on the queenside playing
with that open a file those are those
are a lot of all of those they factor in
all those add up
all right we got a Sicilian
I guess they're looking to kill me
they're gonna go with the Kings Indian
attack so let's go for this setup where
I keep my f-pawn free
and maybe I play f5 at some point maybe
I could still play e5 but let's um
let's go it's rip b8 and B 5 B 4 all
right can't lock down is that really
good square for the Queen we're gonna
find out
let's just swing the back completely
around before on board let's ask him a
question
Wow really giving me the
pair
they can't be really looking to attack
me when they've given up their dark
square bishop and I have master defender
here on g7
okay do we do well I feel like I want my
queen here for some reason I gotta go
faster they've spent a little to no time
watch out for an e5 break I want to do
this or maybe this and then double up
let's take once
and you know let's get this night
exchanged i'ma fear I want to have my
queen see this much more directly III
was fearing maybe a d4 move
let's try this prepared to take out
their night and maybe try to show that
my dark square bishop is better than
their light square bishop
all right we're gonna take here and I'll
look to give him back by going here hmm
where's that night headed I don't know I
want to get into the second-ranked
maybe I should have played queen here
and then and then gone with this move
I'm uh
[Music]
I'm playing without a plan also the
Queen can't do this she has a
responsibility currently
to watch over c3 I'm just gonna go here
seems really really active I don't see
how she could be chased away so easily
now look g8 and a bishop move that's
gonna play Knight g4 Brooke h1 try and
scare me scare away my queen
this has to be pretty scary though some
Bishop discovery threatened
yeah
let's go here
I didn't want to take because I'm
helping out the Queen see this square
[Music]
I don't like my rook over here now
Wow I feel like I'm in some serious
trouble
I am in some serious trouble
my god
I am in some serious trouble they they
just have to pile up on the G file and I
don't have anything now I have to bring
my queen back to defend my bishop or
actually this they could take my pawn
thou to
okay my rook is silly now I have at
least this Square to defend my bishop
just want to get that pawn back Queen f6
should hold everything but I only have
23 seconds
he likes clean here
there's that move
night here I could take twice wow I'm
just barely holding this together very
little time on the clock though
let's go here
that's a pin they're still in the pin
stealing a pin I feel like I'm winning
it made it seven seconds oh they have
that
in check
or seconds
you
no time
you
oh my god my heart is racing my heart is
racing I wasn't saying anything but I'm
sure if you listened close enough maybe
you heard my heart pounding through my
chest that is so ridiculous
that G file opening up
oh man
all right but no any land
mmm-hmm lucky lucky lucky lucky very
lucky somebody's saying crazy yeah I
agree
crazy lucky is a good description crazy
lucky see if they allow b5b for I got to
go faster my time and I don't know don't
know what to say
there's only 18 minutes left
okay
and allow me to play here I'm doing it
even if it allows a knight to move with
the discovery
I want my bishop on g2 to see the world
I want one minor piece exchanged and if
I could get that King Knight exchanged
I'm happy within this structure it's
easier to find adequate squares good
squares for my pieces so
well where does my queen belong it's not
a happy square and I'm going to go here
I want to be able to go here
and where else is my night gonna go so I
need to get this move in to finish
development so let's do it
clamping down on this structure we get
some more exchanges let's do this first
if I did that straightaway they take and
then they're gonna win the exchange so
rook did his job he recaptured on e5 and
now we jump in here we may have another
minor piece or two exchanged
we are having this the Knights are gone
this is an important defender but I
don't know with so few pieces especially
without Knights around I don't know how
much of an issue would be you know can
can black really take advantage of these
uh holes on my King's side it's to be
determined
I may actually think about f4
what do i one do here F for exchange
first just Bishop to d2
how about we just do this Oh No
they're lining up some kind of hon storm
it would be very sensible
five I may have to play f3 Queen f5 I
almost I'm trying to like provoke this
move because I think it's just getting
in the way of that pawn
actually I have to come all the way back
I'm just realizing that now if I went to
eat to push takes pawn push hits with
the fork I'm in trouble
I am in trouble do I play f3
I may need to just play b3 the one thing
I have going for me is the clock here so
they're giving up a pawn
why they are going to free up that
bishop actually I don't even want to
take that pawn
I want to activate my bishop
here and then here if this is ever a
fear
yeah I don't want this pawn to move this
is Bishop striking at my Queen side this
square being available to both Queen and
Bishop this diagonal being open towards
my king
I have the safer home for my king I
don't know something quick let's
centralize their queen is now the only
one there to defend their pawn
dark-squared bishop exchange actually
now maybe things are different where I
can take and then take here because I am
supporting this I could take here can't
I
Rick takes for a queen f5 rook takes for
Queen f5 I double they put more pressure
here I have f3 if Queen takes pawn I
take the rook
I think I could take care
Queen f5 rook here and then up oh my god
totally missed that move but I do have
this and I'm on there Queen should have
at least considered it there under ten
when I was a this is very very shaky
game very very shaky let's just take the
rook
and
do you anything just don't fall for a
makin one no time
yeah they were like they played that
game like I did a couple of my previous
games
a little on the slower side alright
let's try a Carol con against Andy town
all righty in exchange karo with c4
no no payoff Botvinnik attack going
straight in for Bishop deployments okay
Queen a4 Bishop d7 I have to experiment
more with just Queen to c7 that's
supposed to be one of the better
approaches to the exchange karo doc
queen a4 is the move to play there
all right so light square bishop
exchange is definitely a welcome sight
for me this is a bad bishop for a good
bishop exchange I have to take with the
night Queen has a responsibility and
that Queen on a5 her post runs into well
I could hang on let's let's return this
night here stop any 95 stuff I was going
to say is that I gained a valuable
temple at some point against the Queen
expanding with this now minority attack
so that's nice let's circle into the c-4
square I wouldn't mind seeing all minor
pieces exchanged
I think in the end my major pieces will
put pressure
on one of the queenside ponds this is a
really strong Bishop let's challenge him
like this not on f6 because if they
support it with f4 I get out of the way
and then I threaten f6
case in point
I could have done the same with f6 could
have ducked
so I think I will go in for this I'm
Bishop short on squares f6 to the threat
I believe they have to play f5 and give
me a pawn
it won't be the healthiest of ponds but
as they say a pond is upon is upon I'm
gonna take it and now like I want a
piece right here if I can
hmmm let's get to the e-file you know
let's occupy the e-file maybe I just
step up my queen and back up with my
bishop and when the yeah let's step up
with the Queen to defend here connect my
rooks and now we move the bishop out of
the way and the main point behind this
as soon as the bishop moves I play here
and I may be ok with giving up the
exchange even because I will have a pawn
for
if they end up taking it out with my
night this is the only piece that could
challenge hook on this square I have
this is a great strength this opens up
this diagonal Psalm okay let's just um
let's just play some stuff fast I don't
see a way that they could swing over
fast right they're threatening that kind
of stuff now maybe you're trying to
weasel on in here
a Bishop's starting to scare me
let's do this night takes I have queen
takes
i bishop there I think I just want to
anchor the rook here
no they have these squares covered and
the bishops doing a good job the Queen
can't get in so easily just wanna finish
development I'm not thinking about
winning this pawn at all that move okay
we're gonna go here
it may be exchange rooks and then
replace yeah now we know we go here with
the knight
maybe he turns out to be an even better
piece still on a complete development
right here I'm missing anything I have
both of these squares covered it's my
minor pieces 49 seconds maybe I trap the
bishop let's give that a go
and on this move there's Queen takes
pawn but then I take the bishop let's
try for that
they could take this pawn with check but
I
block I'm still in the night they have
to go in for a queen exchange now
otherwise I get into another piece
really down on time I just need to kick
it into higher gear higher gear
don't like my approach
and give some material back try and win
this watch out for the trickiness watch
out for the trickiness just want to
centralize and now target this pawn
it's their night dead he's close to dead
two dead
I could have captured the pond just then
oh they didn't move their night
you
get rid of that night already huh holy
cow man
ah these down-to-the-wire games with how
often they occur you would think I'm
doing them on purpose I'm not doing them
on purpose never do that I don't I
really want I just want to you know like
a smooth no fear on the clock type games
you know just sit back relax convert it
but you know it's just not happening
like that it's not happening I'm not
converting them how I would like to
convert them
what do we do
I don't know c4
welcome
so we're gonna have another Kings Indian
all right let's try a Danish
a stream no let's just go in with the d5
straightaway
accurate maybe night-night to eat - all
right let's go attack
I haven't committed my King just yet and
now that the king is on this square when
I play h5 let f5 isn't working I don't
believe about v h5 and I get to take and
then this so there's a serious problem
so at this point right now I'm
threatening to take and then smash away
on h6 and if they play here it's just I
believe a strategic crush
it's the kind of structure that we're
heat working with where I'm going to
point some pieces at this point
basically I want a light square bishop
exchange I want to play against their
dark square bishop
and I'm not going to take I'm this pawn
is very valuable to me I want to keep
him around he's he's killing this square
and let's get in let's get in B for
right now how am I going to exchange
light square bishop something like this
is the plan let's castle knight on g3 at
some point
[Music]
let's put this rook here and maybe I
don't even Kian on this square just yet
maybe I use this night to put some
pressure on this pawn think I like this
idea here here maybe I even double rooks
on the B file I will at some point
return to this square this is the
weakest point on blacks King side all
right I don't see anything fancy
happening with some sacrifice you do
have to be on the lookout for that but
they don't have none of their minor
pieces are converging twice on any of
these as squares over here okay now they
are let's back this Bishop up to lend
some support to g4 you know that maybe I
should have taken some extra precaution
I'm going to do that right now because
they're ready to go Queen c8
or not on stubble
I don't need pressure on this point
anymore
just put my Knights somewhere else I'm
not a big fan of how I'm going about
regrouping here
can I just capture away on v5 I don't
think they have enough support for that
take with the night first okay they're
just doing that let's push with this
palm
you
this is a it's a bit clumsy
what I'm doing here it's a it's very
clumsy what I'm doing
let's stick with the pond
there's a much better approach that
and actually I could have pushed I could
have pushed and then played a five I
forgot that I have enough support for
that that would have been good acquire a
connected passed pawn that is very deep
Erica's just too active let's get rid of
them
they're also down on time let's just
pack up now they're taking
all right I get my night doing something
there Bishop isn't playing but they have
a they have a weigh-in tonight see three
30-second mark there in a pin ninth seed
393 still step up get to the a file
still no sacrifices over here offer a
queen exchange okay let's put pressure
on that night okay I need my king over
here I believe
here I think is okay okay with this
I guess here the rook is really active I
do not like that
yeah now they're just they're pitching
pawns
I have that covered enough let's just
convert this there's don't I mean we're
not even going to get another game
and I just pushed this guy already
and they're down on time it's gonna be
the last one yeah I mean the pairings
are closed right away man not too many
games in there nine
yes he can't expect too many 57 minute
tournament three Oh time control seems
like I'm gonna get third yeah this one's
this guy's paused unless this guy's
gonna sneak in a quick game he's in a
game right now doesn't seem like it's
close to over 34 33 26 all it's fire
yeah
interesting group of games here
yeah Wireless in the chat here on twitch
is saying that the draw really hurt yeah
definitely when that draw hits at that
what was it round three
the moment where you're ready to hit
that floor especially for a 3o time
control tournament that definitely is
rough
okay 171 were in this one not a bad
turnout at all let's see all the pages
two-three-four yeah this is a really
nice turnout for what time is it's 11:50
7 p.m. where I'm at of course okay
almost there that's gonna do it
okay to the 170 of you good games oh
nice
um also thank you - who is that Z X Y Z
thank you very much for the 200 bits
appreciate that
you